peu
[Musique]
où
[Rires]
[Musique]
dangereuse cargaison que transportait le
baya vers cayenne une cargaison humaine
et de la plus terrible humanité qui soit
voleurs escrocs et assassin l'équipage
les gardiens les surveiller de près
sachant que la moindre seconde
d'inattention leur serait fatale le
bayard en est également des passagers
fonctionnaires regagner leurs postes et
les familles de gardiens dont le
commandant bar h on était fort inquiet
de la présence à bord de femmes de
l'administration pénitentiaire lui avait
imposé de misérables créatures qu'on
appelait des relégués dix minutes de
promenade quotidienne il reste du temps
les bagnards étaient entassés comme des
animaux dans ce qu'on appelait
commodément des cages ou plus
plaisamment la ménage
[Musique]
ouais ce que je reproche à cher aîné
mais c'est d'avoir chaud avec l'âge on
cale du mca-bénin de verrières origines
n'ont qu'à pas importer leurs groupies
dans la tombe
tu vois ce que l on fait autant de
victimes de son bois et qu'elle n'aurait
jamais fait ça c'est à dire c'est sacré
j'aime bien parce qu'il a voulu s'il
n'était pas au cachot vraiment que la
boucle on l'a vu comme il a craché sur
eppinger du commandant barrachin et
comment le commandant une à filer doux
chocottes
[Musique]
comment alors effectué tous ses fromages
12 jurés qui nous mène procès le
condamné à mort
ils ont tous peur de chez rémi causse
ouais
n'empêche qu'il aurait pas du tout avec
la jonquère de l'admirer même pour les
peaux tient le mentor kanak si le
respecte il es ma came dans son
amphithéâtre
[Musique]
le kanak l'intellectuel de la bande
le second de chéri bibi ancien médecin
il avait été condamné à dix ans de
travaux forcés pour n'avoir pas voulu
dire à quoi lui servaient les lanières
de chair qu'il venait de découper sur un
de ses clients encore vivant
c'est ça qui sont mal rangés c'est
inadmissible inadmissible en danger les
voûtes aux affaires qui est chef
d'escouade ici c'est moins deux jours de
cachot choix six jours à les accrocher
dans les bacs est accroché mais les bacs
et v
désormais le lavage des cages sera fait
par une série d'ennemis à cet effet soit
briquet comme le salon du commandant
vous m'avez compris canarie portant le
commandant barachois dignement dans le
voilà le commandant 24 heures de cachot
vous apprendre à être si rude en service
bravo pas de soupe demain vous serez au
pain sec pain sec et à l'eau
et alors c'est pour aujourd'hui ou pour
demain ce sera quand chéri bibi le vôtre
s'il a craché à la figure du commandant
d'arrachement oui c'est uniquement pour
ce faire m cash ou alors le canal c'est
comme qui dirait son quartier général
particulier franchement
[Musique]
ouaddou mes choix de cajou alors je t'ai
bien savoir à quoi de tenir du bien
après qu'ils soient tous d'accord pour
la revente
un peu oui paraîtrait qu on fera les
corsaires on sera les rois de l'océan
alors là mon petit viol gare à ceux qui
vont me tomber dessus très bien convenir
à caracas où il ya une révolution on se
mettrait au service des insurgés pour se
rendre maître du bateau ou est ce qu'on
va trouver sa forme il ya le même vu une
mitraille
zhu elle n'est pas pour nous mon genou à
la première ouverture des cages où j'ai
trait sur les gardes sur le second sur
tout ce qui se trouvera là ensuite on
ouvrait à
les autres aux cages avant que là où
seulement sages devraient leur taux est
certaine elles vont tirer et mater
louvre à dîner nous concevons massacré
haut de gamme on ne fait pas d'omelette
sans casser des oeufs
ce sera comme au temps de la révolution
chéri bibi cadets si tu vois une preuve
qu'on aura des armes quand on voudra
fouilles au fond dedans ça
[Musique]
oh bon sang mais c'est dur on n'en a
plus y en a plus tôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous ne savez pas qu'il est interdit de
santé non auriez-vous par hasard a envie
d'aller rejoindre au 3216 à fond de cale
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est beau mais c'est juré bbc chéri
bibi vous faites une enquête monsieur
vilaine et si la faute de garde vous
punissez était bien content et c'est moi
des bouteilles dans les cages mais c'est
comme de la dynamite ça absolument
savoir ce qui est imaginable que je suis
tout à fait d'accord mais ce que je
trouve le plus fort c'est que les jurés
n'est pas condamner tous ces bandits à
la peine de mort quand tout ce dont vous
y voyez ces tracas comme nous il est
probable qu'ils regretteraient leurs
faiblesses
je dirais même l'acheter et oui les
jurés avaient eu peur
par crainte de la fameuse bande à chéri
bibi l'avait exigé du président des
assises que des policiers les
raccompagne à ça près le procès jusque
chez eux et que même la nuit
la sûreté nationale continue à veiller
sur leurs précieuses personnes le seul
dans ce procès qui ne montera nulle
crainte de chéri bibi et l inspecteur
costaud son ennemi juré
soyons ambitieux il faut débarrasser une
fois pour toutes la société de ce bandit
mais les jurés n'avaient pas suivi les
conseils de monsieur costaud il avait eu
peur une fois de plus et une fois de
plus il avait expédié chéri bibi aubagne
au lieu de l'envoyer à la guillotine on
va bien tout va bien comme à lens
j'ai souvent regretté que ces
instruments sont encore en service et
bien maintenant c'est faire digne de
l'inquisition me semble trop doux pour
un pareil forcené wallonie c'est le
crime qui valent tout son cynisme sans
nom commence à 100 long puisqu'il
s'appelle thierry b
barton je risquerais de le tuer je
regretterai toute ma fille chez moi je
vous en félicite ray toute la mienne qui
était bonne à tous vous connaissez la
consigne de se relever tout et deux
heures ne jamais parler et ne jamais
répondre aux numéros 3216 il risque ce
monstre devais rire de la même façon que
tu te couper la tête
heureusement pour tout le monde qui va
crever bientôt vous voyez on pressent
que certains commandants il supportera
jamais les faire jusqu'au bout sa bosse
ou même un cas de conscience
la conscience ils habitent ces bandits
ce serait plutôt de la conscience oui
tout de même je préfère qu'il arrive
entier à cayenne
oh pardon excusez moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
le style très mal et se fait dans la vie
saine vous voyez bien je vais distribuer
la soupe on appelait cette femme la
comtesse condamné en même temps que son
amant le kanak
on se posait à leur sujet là même fatale
question était un entrepôt fages mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous n'allez pas pleurer comme ça tout
le temps donc comme des mots qu'est ce
qui tracasse un remake
matin
emma de vilaine que se passe-t-il
ils se passent commande entre le devenir
au 3216 s'est évadé chéri des billets il
n'est plus dans son cachot râle c'est
impossible nous venons de le quitter
les deux gardiens mort la relève bien de
les trouver étranglée dans quelques
jours les fers sont toujours cadenassé
mais chéri bibi a disparu il ya qu une
clé et j'ai toujours sur moi d'ailleurs
la voix la barre ou chéri bibi et est il
sorti tout est en place il n'y avait
nulle trous dans les murs et la porte
était toujours fermée alors malheureux
il se pend voler tout de même chéri bibi
voulez que je vous dise comment dans le
savez là où dans les cages il était trop
joyeux trop à la rigolade depuis deux
jours et je vais vous donner un conseil
sauf le respections doigts c'est par eux
qu'on sera quelque chose à bord du
bayard on appelait ce petit manège la
bourse aux secrets pour correspondre
avec leurs compagnes d'infortuné les
bagnards utilisaient les services
intéressés des matelots du navire et de
certains surveillants militaire au coeur
trop tendre ces âmes sensibles sevré de
présence féminine y trouvait certes leur
compte mais au prix de quelles monnaies
la comtesse elle aussi s'était évadé
cela faisait beaucoup pour le commandant
d'un seul jour comment chéri bibi
c'était une défaite ces liens comment
avait il rejoint la potasse c'est par ce
temps question s'échapper ils n'iront
pas bien loin
ce trou mène à la cale aux marchandises
c'est un vrai cul de sac non pas que
maintenant chéri bibi et a remis vous
avez raison
j'ai une idée allons chercher les gardes
parce qu commandant surveiller ce
trouble si j'avais raconté son chéri
bibi essayer d'en sortir est leur
affaire
quand il sombra commandant va d'abord
des décharges général autour de
l'échelle
attendez je suis fou reptiles peu lui
importe
il vaut mieux tuer les gens
réglementairement
numéro 3216 rendez vous si vous prendre
ses marques
j'ai cru voir muet quelque chose je vous
ai dit que je voulais faire des
sommations réglementaire numéro 3216
rené vous une fois deux fois trois fois
allez tirer sur tout ce qui bouge
pascoe vous n'avez rien vu rien
commandant je veuille continuer qui a
tiré le premier
c'est moi que moi je vous dit quelque
chose me filer entre les jambes ça
devait être un rat le drain on est plein
il aura le culot de passer par là il
plateau le drain lassante in du navire
était la dernière chose qui fut au fond
du bâtiment un étroit boyau dans lequel
venait se déverser tous les trucs tus du
navire pour oser prendre un tel chemin
même quand on s'appelle chéri bibi
il faut sentir la mort à ses trousses
comme n'importe comment deux précautions
valent mieux qu'une
[Musique]
vous étiez dieu pourra peut-être pitié
une
[Musique]
oui
vous
[Musique]
plus
hamelin
ouais pourtant le croyait tous
increvable costaud comme il était on n'a
pas empêché de présenter une telle
naissance
chez bébé
il
cogéré dominion
bon
[Musique]
e
où
[Musique]
en tout cas la commande en vous avez une
bonne idée
oui et nous avons fait coup double les
bannières sont calmés les passagers sont
rationnels pas que chéri bibi et la
femme des kanak se porte à merveille
il court toujours
regardez comme ils sont dociles nulle
part c'est triste
regardez commandant j'avais raison c'est
le dénommé gueule de bois
allez vite que j'achète papier si vous
permettez commandant attendons plutôt de
voir si les testings cette religieuse
que l'ordre de saint-vincent-de-paul
envoyé à l'hôpital de cayenne est aimé
et respecté de tous sur le navire
bagnards équipage et passagers
reconnaissait à la vocation charitable
deux soeurs sainte-marie-des-anges un
élan impérieux qui forçait l'admiration
[Musique]
soeur sainte-marie-des-anges nom de dieu
parce que je vous en prie permettez ma
soeur mais commando vous n'allez tout de
même pas entré chez vous si ma soeur à
moins que vous ne remettez le bien
qu'ils billet je ne comprends pas le
billet vert a passé sur le pont je ne
sais pas ce que vous voulez dire vous
savez très bien ma chère je suis effrayé
de vous entendre comme être à pareille
manchon quel but poursuivent ou en
communiquant ainsi avec les forçats vous
savez que c'est très grave
mais comment dont je vous assure
chéri bibi n'est pas mort il est venu il
est la commande ans j'ai vu cheaibi j'ai
reconnu ses yeux son nez il est là cette
façon quand on me les a suscité
seychelles libye j'ai entendu hyaric en
effet chez les bébés vivant nous allons
aider toutes les cales toutes les
capitales
[Musique]
ils finiront bien tous les deux par
crever de faim ou de soif c'est pas
évident s'ils sont dans lesquelles ils
ont toujours de quoi manger
une chose est certaine ils ont des
complices à bord pour les ravitailler
quelle que soit sa doit savoir qu'il
soit exécuté sans pitié un temps chez
les bébés pas faire attention avec vos
histoires ça donne la chair de poule et
et ça me fait trembler au cette nature
quitte avec lui il voulait fusiller
aussi commandant j'ai dit qu'il se soit
sur le champ
fusillé bon duo joie
[Musique]
et
vous
[Musique]
il
oui oui et ses tables tout de suite le
papier le papier
c'est un petit côté misé sur sanary des
anges à l'infirmerie qu'on la soigne
surtout quand la surveille dentelle
cassant le seuil des 10 on n'a pas
encore touché le tour dans l'hôtel et
l'accueil du match aller avant ce disque
il pas à les rendre capitaine thomas
capitaine basque ou mai mais comment
êtes vous entré ici
la porte était fermée à clé de
l'extérieur non plus en soirée ici comme
dans un moulin victoire je peux même pas
vous enlevez les faire c'est le
commandant qui a la clé je vais la
chercher
maintenant il n'est plus question de
tergiverser ma soeur ça ne sert qu'à
prolonger une situation équivoque qui me
nuit autant casser et après tout vous
avez peut-être raison
je vous écoute ma seule
[Musique]
si j'ai pris le voile c'est pour me
consacrer à la rédemption des bagnards
veiller à leur salut éternel comme le
faisait le bon monsieur saint vincent de
paul rude tâche mais il s'agit d'une
tâche encore plus terrible que vous
l'imaginez il s'agit de gérer pipi
voulait convertir ce monstre
sauver cet assassin oui c'est retirer
tout cela mais
c'est encore
oui il ya beaucoup de belles
performances si vous arrivez à gonfaron
commentaires il est surtout le confrère
je vous êtes sa soeur amateurs oui mon
frère c'est inouï c'est inouï
et pardonnez moi vous n'avez coupé bras
et jambes chéri bibi le frère du monstre
rn16 dieu s'y retrouvent dans cette
famille je commence à en avoir marre
je sais bien que c'est pour quand je
chéris du big boi mémoire comment sam à
lui à andy de la viande au soir
[Musique]
ces jugements est la preuve que c'est
pour bientôt
[Musique]
c'est pour caf et mines a subi imminent
chéri bibi entendez la voix de votre
soeur et entendez la voix de la sagesse
allez-vous nous fusillerons pas au gal
deux mois séri bi bi sache que si je
meurs avant toi je te pardonne c'est la
soeur de série b
s'ils n'ont trouvé que ça pour rattraper
sans vraiment pas fort j'ai accédé à
tous vos désirs
nous avons fouillé partout nous voilà
même dans la cuisine voyez pas le style
de la ficelle tétouan mais il faut se
rendre à l'évidence ce gredin ne viendra
pas c'est bien toi de tes affaires veux
tu il a oublié que c'est moi qui les
baptiser ses débits l'amour quand il
j'ai chéri bibi qui maintient au dessus
des blessés non non il s'est enfui par
l'escalier qui conduit aux cabines ou
tenant monde hippique
[Musique]
c'est fluide et oui ce cirque à 1 vous
croyez que ce sérieux de sauter aux gens
comme ça aux sénateurs un voyez pas que
le travail et tout mais pas dans la
soupe chérissent effet dit oui
j'oubliais un qui vous paraît ma peau
[Musique]
vous aviez raison ma soeur
rembourser un écuyer en chef elle nous
avons dieu
[Musique]
on
non
salle sainte marie des anges et
d'envolées oui je sais faire vite monter
aussi toujours
[Musique]
écoutez de vilaine moi j'en peux plus
continuer tout seul je rejoindrai dans
un moment nous avons peut-être une
chance de rattraper maintenant seul
sainte marie des anges avec sap est sûr
c'est un poids pour eux ni et puis une
cornette ça se repère facilement
enfin espérons
[Musique]
rester assis quand
on va
[Musique]
noah
maintenant écoutez moi bien
je suis un honnête homme
vous l'été
j'aurais pu l'être
fatalitas
[Musique]
la fatalité
voilà ma ce donc
soucy et comment ce que j'ai pu avoir
comme des veines dans la vie d'abord si
un maître quelques choses au point on
dit anarchiste
c'est complètement fou moi je trouve la
société très bien fait
mon désir a toujours été de me faire une
honorable place
fatalitas j'ai lu quand bodkin est
reclus leur tort il tient pas debout
quant à karl marx alors là inutile de
vous dire je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec lui sans effet les efforts
parfois surhumains pour m'approprier
biens d'autrui faudrait que je le
partage avec des gens que je ne connais
pas et le coeur sur la main à la main
sur la conscience vous me débarquer et
je vous promets que je n'aurai plus
jamais embêté mais semblable
j'attends vos décisions
[Musique]
je dois vous amener à cayenne tard
également les phares mais je me fous du
règlement c'est oui ou c'est non c'est
non à l'état vous l'aurez voulu comment
dans les mains en l'air par ici mais
vous verrez votre destin commandant
celui que vous avez choisi maintenant
vous mettez la menteuse au repos jo
brute la cervelle pas y aller
[Musique]
attention commandant chaibi derrière je
suis
j'aurais dû m'en douter une fetwa la
ficelle le complexe de libye
et elle se dirige pas vite et si vous
tentez d'appeler aux gardois tireur
attention je vous fais sauter le caisson
bruit ailleurs on descend
[Musique]
temps mort
on
parce qu'au début le commandant non
capitaine enfin je comprends pas je vais
moi même accompagné jusqu'à sa porte
tout à l'heure et chez les bibites
toujours rien bannon capitaine et pour
l'instant on a fouillé partout
et ça me dérange introuvable si je
comprends bien chéri bibi a disparu la
comtesse a disparu sur sainte-marie a
disparu et le commandant gamme
disparaître le commando ils étaient
offerts à la place de gueule de bois
lequel avait remplacé monsieur de wilhem
lequel il y avait succédé à chéri bibi
ce n'était plus un cache-nez une
pochette surprise
[Applaudissements]
à
mr la comtesse quel [ __ ] qui
atterrissent au public
[Musique]
vous
à
[Musique]
non nous avoir à l'hectare tu fais deux
montés sur le pont supérieur
planquez vous la gamme et bas
[Musique]
ça fait un moment qu'ils tirent plus
capitaine vous les avez complètement
cloud et ils peuvent plus rien cei
ja qu'est ce que je vous disais ils se
rendent à lvov eux comme chez libye
sorte le premier
9e on leur promet un commandant
maintenant si vous voulez tirer pour les
vaches ils ont aucune moralité
allez ne viennent même pas la veste est
roulée vous déposez vos armes
sinon il n'y a plus de barrages on ne
l'écouté pas tyreke mavilor si la vente
à la capitelle n'avons pas le droit de
sacrifier la vie du commandant déposer
les armes
petit lait si vous mettez jamais ici
vous mélangez de rigueur
[Rires]
travaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faut m'excuser c'est un lay part tout
seul et la ficelle
c'est pas moi qui fais gaffe sur gaffe
et saute et phobies c'est djibi jerry
pipi
[Applaudissements]
le commandant je viens vous avertir que
le second a déjà calculé langue
l'horaire dans la matinée où et qui se
dispose à prendre la tangente de
l'américaine et dans les foyers pas
faire le malin sous prétexte qu'on a été
à l'école un sac à l'essai par terre au
point c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse
c'est qu'il fasse peau mais ma cravate
et je passe la rue dulong tuba ouais de
débrouiller pour trouver quelque chose
qui doit être un jeu fait plus l'amour
l'espagnol à titre privé bon maintenant
messieurs
passons aux choses sérieuses
[Musique]
voir
on prend
baroin
très bien
elle tend lui le règlement aux hommes
mais commandant seul et même faire
afficher dans toute la corse il
et la voilà d'ailleurs je suis et la
discipline sont les deux seuls maîtres à
bord en ma seule personne ce sont les
choses sacrées personne n'a le droit de
rigoler avec sa état-major compris
à bord on est maîtres queux de l'air
qu'on respire et encore si on l'a dans
l'estomac vrai bien
repos
du shérif a plus de chéri bibi il n'y a
que le temps en temps dit commandant
cassetti qu'on va à caracas faire de la
révolution est devenu ministre et sur
intempestives le seul ministre à bord
c'est moi ainsi le calme était revenu à
bord en même temps que l'ordre le plus
strict
[Musique]
obama
le règlement connaît en trois points
article 1er il n'y a plus de chéri bibi
il n'y a plus que le commandant article
2 le commandant est seul maître à bord
et on lui doit le respect article 3 pas
de rouge pétant bref nos gagnants
avaient retrouvé la liberté
l'entaillé comment la votre dévoué l'a
pas le temps je travaille travaille
comme andorre c'est le 3216 votre
préféré le 3207 oui pour tout de suite
on entre avec 216 entrée
hausse des commandes en voulez savoir à
ses bobards h on vous voulez vous chéri
bibi a il n'y a plus de chirée billy non
la plupart commandant compris bien
bachand est bon mix nous nous reverrions
nous aurions un petit entretien afin je
vous apporte les preuves de mon
innocence
thierry
balshaw
signer à dieppe m'appelle jacques masse
car jacques les lions du pavillon dans
la propriété de nous mettre débout
relier les avait deux enfants
robert un sale gamin son importance et
cécile mélange de douceur
des dents et et les serviteurs de ces
bourgeois respectable et riche
les bourreaux lierse avait souvent le
marquis et la marquise du touch aéré qui
habitait juste de château à côté de leur
propriété
maxime du toucher leur fils avait
entraîné dans la débauche robert
beaulieu
ce qui n'empêchait pas le vieux père
bourrelier de voir maxime du toucher
pour genre à cause de la noblesse la
noblesse barachois
cecily elle n'aimait pas maxime non un
certain penchant pour son cousin marcel
qui naviguait sur les mers de chine
ouais tout ça ça me désole
parce que pour moi c'est si dur
c'était la pureté mon instituteur et où
le jeu soyons honnête et pas que j'avais
des dons pour tirer les plans et bien
pour avoir la joie de continuer à voir
la tendre cecily j'ai préféré quitter
l'école et je suis rentré dans la
boucherie vois pas le rapport
la boucherie l'arracheront la boucherie
le matin quand j'avais livré la viande
je voulais voir cecily ne serait ce que
5 minutes
non
à 1
on
[Musique]
m
le
[Musique]
e
où
bon
là
[Musique]
oh
mon
allonge
barachois
alors pour la première fois ma ration
j'ai rencontré la fatalité soit requise
et vendant sur la falaise
j'ai aperçu le père bourrelier qui se
battent et juste au bord du gouffre avec
un homme à grand chapeau un grand
chapeau arrive on voyait même pas le
visage sous le chapeau alors je criais
mais bon j'arrive à vitesse il a eu un
sursaut il s'est retourné je vais
frapper à la place de la manche savons
que ce ne sera pas à sa place
il tombait à mes pieds
il était mort j'avais été à la place de
l'homme au chapeau
j'avais tué celui que je voulais sauver
j'avais tué le père de saisie
chéri bibi à la tête des forces à s'est
emparé du bayard qui cingle vers cayenne
maître du navire il y fait régner une
discipline de fer tant sur ses hommes
que sur les anciens gardiens descendu
dans les cages voulant toujours se
justifier prouver son innocence
il déclare à l'ex commandant barachois
médusés je suis victime de la fatalité
la fatalité la fatalité pont djamarat
change vous éclater à territet profitant
du désarroi la mouche progrès s'était
enfui sur ma bicyclette
j'y suis de le poursuivre
en vain
c'est alors je me suis souvenu mon
couteau eh oui
mon couteau de seigneur mon couteau de
boucher et mon tablier disparu et on l'a
retrouvé
fatalitas et des jeunes
monsieur à foley
sur touré sur la falaise story la
fatalité toujours là sa qualité qui
continue ses salles manigances
[Musique]
mon tablier avait disparu mon couteau
avait disparu le canal de monsieur
bourrelier était parti et mon vélo lui
il est garant du notre père nous a
quittés fait exactement le chemin de la
planète va déjà être rentré à la maison
maman il s'est dit surpris à regarder
une bicyclette curieux on dirait salle
de chéri bibi faudrait pas qu'il ait
qu'un accident jeu des savoirs sur la
grèce bizarre missile peut peut-être un
homme at il rencontré autant par mon
cher robert au regard des du sang sans
trop de bruit que ce ne soit pas celui
de mon père accès
des précédents mais face à vous
regardez c'est affreux
au père c'est abominable
et comment mais sûrement eu un malaise
et il est tombé et que c'était entre ses
membres et amis
oui c'est un tablier de boucher ça vous
dirait que c'est pas un tournant qui
s'est tué qu'est ce que tu veux dire
pour marie ça ressemble à une trace de
coups de couteau son portefeuille a
disparu et oui marathon le portefeuille
avait disparu alors j'ai assisté tout
stable avec impuissance
alors je me suis enfui
pourtant ça aurait été la sagesse de
vous rendre avec un bon avocat
donc la seule chance qui me restait
c'était de retrouver l'homme au chapeau
gris de le traîner devant un juge
et puis là tout s'explique alors je vais
jetter jour et nuit
j'étais soeur qui revient et rodez sur
les lieux de son crime cela jour et nuit
bars à chaud
et puis alors un soir alors qu'ils
épuisent et j'allais moi dormir je t'ai
vu passer comme une ombre et je fus
stupéfait barachois de voir que l'homme
au chapeau gris me diriger vers le
château du marquis de toucher car je
suis heureux très bas autour du château
tout est obscur marienne bouger et voilà
t'y pas d'arrachement rien dis pas que
couteau qui avait tant cherché mais au
couteau mon couteau de boucher volatile
par contre retrouver dans la poitrine
tu martin du touch et c'est pas les
mêmes c'est la raison aux les mains elle
prévient la police
la fatalité vachon elle me quitte elle
ne faut pas faire un pas fatalité comme
je comprends les wii pour le premier
meurtre c'était un accident et pour le
second une machination très plaisir
après cette confession surprenant tout
rentra dans l'ordre le kanak faisait
marcher le baya lâche laurent me gardait
les gardes les familles des gardes
avaient été rassuré par la promesse de
série b b- parle du commandant chéri
bibi qu'il ne leur serait fait aucun mal
et qu'on l'ait débarquerait au plus tôt
bref si l'on excepte l'état de santé de
seurre sainte marie des anges et la
morosité des anciens gardes
l'atmosphère était plutôt à la liesse
mal
les exercices que le kanak s'acharnait à
imposer commandant commandant de vigie
signale des naufragés par tribord avant
[Musique]
on
fatalitas
à quelques encablures du bayard une
embarcation dans laquelle se trouvait
maxime du toucher et robert bourgi chéri
bibi ne savait plus que penser surtout
après la longue conversation qu'il
venait d'avoir avec sa seule et moi tout
tout ce qui peut bien encore me faire
détester cette canaille qui m'a précédé
n'est jamais là ils se désintéressent
complètement de son petit garçon
il essayait sans argent on ce n'est pas
tout les souvient le château du toucher
et bien il l'a fait quitter à cécile il
ya sa vieille mère pour y installer une
de ses maîtresses supporter ça que c'est
la chine je veux et quand je n'ai jamais
personne même ce que tu assassines et je
suis jamais un sens tout un innocent
persécutés tu te crois
du moins en ce qui concerne le meurtre
du marquis du toucher à ce que tu dis je
dis que j'ai la conviction que tu n'as
pas tuer le vieux renard qui je ne suis
pas je me fais bouillir le sang le
parole jeudi que maxime du touchet à
fait à notre âge inouïe ac c'est lié à
la vieille marquise en installant cette
femme au château chasse et sa mère de
son château
non par de nouveaux mots là j'arrive pas
à me retenir je comprends c'est une
courtisane sûrement quelques aventures
gare de bastringue ont pas du tout une
femme du monde
la baronne pro scorff et tout le monde
l'a surnommée la belle dita comme le
bateau de maxime selon yash oui cette
femme là un mari on dit que cet homme a
vendu à maxime du toucher pour un
million dont ça se paiera un jour comme
le reste
si jamais je coince là mon cher progrès
maintenant même si chacun photo me dira
tout
qui est cette personne qui croit en mon
innocence c'est grave très grave si elle
sait cela c'est qu'elle connaît levrat
est coupable l'homme au chapeau gris
tu te souviens de rien
la gouvernante de la marquise oui suivez
toujours c'est m oui elle était très
attachée au vieux marquis et la marquise
le même sembler un poteau qu offre ce
soir là j'étais encore plus bizarre que
d'habitude et c'est cette nuit là qu que
j'ai eu un semblant d'explication
ne faites pas de bruit c'est moi pauvre
petit jacqueline pauvre chéri bibi votre
frère est innocent ce n'est pas lui qui
a tué le martyr c'était un autre un
autre c'est tout ce que je sais chéri
bibi je te la firme devant dieu qui vous
écoute
fatalitas
[Musique]
des ennuis en perspective pour nous
alors
pour une fois la fatalité mal album
tout n'a pas recueilli
vrai pas couramment qu'il ya se rendent
comme ça avec la raison google bande
d'abrutis avec l'arrivée c'est le fera
je vais devenir riche riche le présente
comme un embarras shonda marine
nationale
capitaine du bayard marquis maxime du
touch est propriétaire et commandant de
laval dieppoise coulé corps et biens
ravie je vous présente le baron bros kof
qui la grande douleur de perdre sa femme
pendant ce naufrage
je compatis baron bon allez répétons
[Musique]
alors toi qu'est ce que tu as fait
mais cabochard
tu es ce que tu as fait tu à verser du
plomb fondu dans l'oreille de ta
maîtresse
c'est pourtant pas compliqué jamais une
maîtresse ça m'étonne pas et souhaite
pas verser du plan et ses mains et ses
mains à les toits mange en tête qu'est
ce t'as fait qu'est ce tu as fait ta
gentil belle mais il auspices tu a versé
de l'arsenic dans le chocolat de la
gentille belmaig je veux pas penser mais
pas oublier ça
[Musique]
les images les plus féroces et toi ils
n'ont pas l'air très méchant ni fiez pas
trop
sans les attaques qui se défendent
maintenant mesdames et messieurs la
visite continue tout le monde dans les
cachots parce que nous allons pas chéri
bibi commandant mais ma petite à nous
allons voir si ribéry avec un autre
misérable tu as bien compris si tu
branches
si tu dis quelque chose je te brûle
quel est friand mon dieu quelle ville et
une autre page vraiment il était
épouvantable et maintenant mesdames et
messieurs chéri bibi et on passe par ici
l'équipe dames en avant pour la visite
celui-ci vous dit le monstre des
monstres
on dira un auteur à la retraite non la
visite de la ménagerie est terminée la
terrasse pour les messieurs maintenant
tout le monde sur le pont la fête
commence et un pari perdu dans la ville
sans fond d'une philosophie des ens
paris
le brave commandant varachaud promu au
rôle de chéri bibi ne savaient plus à
quel saint se vouer
[Musique]
mais ils ont l'air méchant maintenant
maintenant le seul endroit sur la terre
madame où l'on peut juger vraiment les
gens sur les harkis les sens pourquoi
parce que le costume de bagnard va
merveilleusement bien à tout le monde
et donc aujourd'hui pourrait dire que le
costume de bagnard ne nuirait pas
le costume de bagnard d'un à chacun leur
petit plus faux personnage ce commandant
[Musique]
raillé gras l'onu et ses chants les
champs plus
[Musique]
la manie en vie
il s'était lancé à droite mmes viendront
bientôt à bord du canot par alléger leur
but
est heureux qu'un tueur de fiction sur
les ponts et dans les coeurs le feu le
feu de leurs oiseaux y porter dans l'île
sur l'épaule le feu de leurs droits dans
[Musique]
chéri bibi
tu diras tu verras ce n'était qu'un
mauvais moment à passer
maintenant je suis sûr que j'ai prise en
charge de tous ses camarades au tableau
temps fêtera ses sept ans meurent tous
d'aplomb tempêté race est propre et rh
et ont été rasées tant pis
et qu'est-ce qui fait ça la tombe et
saboteurs tant pis giambi
[Applaudissements]
et
à c
[Musique]
ok
m
[Musique]
le poteau
vous n'êtes vous pas venues danser avec
nous faire mal venues danser voyons les
antennes à vous gens sont un peu et puis
vous voulez vous vaut bien célébrer
bacchus ils doivent rembourser oubliée
sa mère morte
c'est une femme remarquable
d'une intelligence supérieure est belle
comme le jour
hachey a convaincu manche est
mais bon la remplacerait jamais savez
vous avez la faculté d'oublier très vite
moi pas je me consolerai jamais et vous
ce que je ferai à votre place je
rentrerai auprès de ma femme et
j'attendrai tout tranquillement de
savoir si la part du porte car enfin
sommes sur logne jaloux pas pu être
aussi enlevé par fatou auprès de ma
femme nous faisons paiement cecily et
charmante elle sera ravie de vous revoir
j'ai découvert des choses intéressantes
[Musique]
quand on
ces gens n'ont aucune éducation selon le
rapport de la bri kouame petit il ya
aucun danger ici mais non mais non
allez nous avait promis de danse et de
réciter des vers il faut vous dépêcher
aller vite vite vite vite préparez vous
on vous attend qu'est-ce qui se passe tu
viens pas la fête
non non je crois va l'année
dis-moi comtesse
je sais que tu m'aimes
je ne suis guère payé de retour
ouais je sais
rien n'arrive au moment convenu dans la
vie tu comprends
et puis la place est présente
sage il s'appelait
c'est bien le malheur de ma vie
bon
[Musique]
parlons peu parlons bien puisque tu
m'aimes
est ce que tu es prêt à faire quelque
chose pour moi tout ce que tu voudras
chez régulier
des choses de
les choses tout ce que tu voudras chéri
regarde
et le plus en plus l'impression que nous
sommes tombés dans un traquenard
assieds toi
voilà
oui que tu me dises
oui tu me dis ce que le kanak et wau
faisait les lanières de chair que vous
des croupiers sur l'autre y en a pas ça
tu vois qu'il ya des choses que tu veux
pas faire pour moi alors c'est vrai ce
qu'on raconte
elle a compté c'est vrai que c'est pas
vrai ce n'est pas vrai toujours chéri
bibi sur mon amour pour toi que ce sont
des mensonges sans fil
pourquoi tant pis
j'avais rêvé
de vous donner quelques amants en juin
je sais qui c'est
le marquis
et maxi attend nous jusqu au monde donc
on ne va nulle part si remonter sur le
pont ouais je suis inquiet pendant ça
[Musique]
puisque tu le prends moi je veux bien
que tu saches demande aux kanaks
moi je n'ose pas ce qu'ils te disent
l'affreux dont la tête ne reculera cinq
ans fissures chez lui n'a jamais reculé
devant rien jamais tu veux savoir chez
des bébés et si tu pars
tu vas tomber nos têtes ok moi points
[Musique]
aucune importance la tête
j'étais la dame
[Applaudissements]
la comtesse chercher le kanak
je
[Musique]
on souhaite de tout mon arme que tu ne
regretteras jamais ce qui peut arriver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
montès les bonnes il est retourné à la
danse alors
on a eu toute cette navigation nous
faisant route vers le golfe de guinée
c'est vrai
on jettera départ par dessus bord et on
est prêt à maquiller le bateau parfait
et tu crois que ça a marché on croit
réellement perdu corps et biens 115
troubles pour le chardon nous ferrons
ravitaillement 1 kg ha non c'est toi
ce qui se passe le kanak
on dira est avalé une purge la comtesse
m'a parlé chez des copines
alors pardon
vous pouvez quelque chose pour moi leur
parle oui quelque chose de formidable
mais je crains bien que tu ne refuse
parle je suis régulier du coeur au
ventre il va te falloir ne craignent
rien surtout que ça peut très bien ne
pas réussir ça se tourner autour du pour
la gauche aura voulu gérer bibi tu vas
connaître mon secret mais sache que
dorénavant tout comme - comme la
conteste une dormira jamais plus que la
seule pensée de tenter cette épreuve ta
brûlera comme une robe de flammes
allah
voilà
e
m
[Musique]
e
fatah
chéri bibi avait voulu connaître le
secret le terrible secret du kanak et ce
secret allait le tenter maintenant comme
l' empire du monde avait tenté le
mauvais entre son aventure à lui chéri
bibi est aussi prodigieuse qu'il la
croyait dans son orgueilleuse naïveté la
seule et grande préoccupation du temps
et de l'espace
jusqu alors il ne connaissait pas de
plus remarquable malheur héroïque que le
sien et voilà que fatalitas sous les
traits sinistre du kanak médecins des
chu a menacé lui offrait le plus
terrible des rebondissements que
fatalitas et jamais préparé pour chéri
bibi
j'accepte
si on dit aussi qu'on soit
les amis danois
alou si le pouvoir
jamais le poulet par mon ami est parti
en vérité la cus enragé
open
[Applaudissements]
ouais bien fait passer maxime il a dû
remonter sur le pont mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe il se passe me fais le pari que
ces partis en lice le camarade c'est
pourquoi parce que la wii u dance c'est
le cas femme blonde
non mais faut vous y faire nous sommes
aux mains des bagnards c'est la vérité
par ici
qu'est ce que ça veut dire à mes
camarades je vais pas laisser la tente
en occupe
[Applaudissements]
à rodez
oui vous dirai pas plus loin ça suffit
d'ici là haut tu réfléchis alors
suivez-moi par ici
écoutez moi je vais vous parler
j'ai bien réfléchi
puisque ces dames ne peuvent pas être à
tout le monde eh bien elles seront à
personne je les garde pour ou à seule
fin qu'il leur arrive pas malheur car je
me suis engagée elle est débarquée
salissent aux canards qui les touche et
s'est engagé à racheter la vie les
naufragés contre la somme de 5 millions
encore et vous il est évident que nous
lasserons l'art qui que contre les 5
millions
ça sent les 5 millions ou la mort
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu en penses la pucelle je
connais mon chéri bibi ça sera les 100
millimes et la mort maxime du touch est
nul ne savait pourquoi fut isolé de ses
compagnons d'infortuné
on commença par changer le nom du bateau
qui de bayard devint l'estrela l'on
n'avait plus qu'à s'occuper des
modalités du versement de la rançon
il devra passer pour le secrétaire
particulier des marques qui les touchait
désormais tu t'appelles monsieur il est
monsieur est claire rien dans la salle
bon alors en arrivons à dieppe
ils présenteront notaire mais ton régime
tuant nettoie sa lettre était crédité
qui lui donne tous les détails et simpl
pognon t'inquiète pas il te me donnera
la lettre et la croix pour l'écriture du
marquis c'est intolérable
parfaitement nous voulons voir le
marquis malade mais la dernière fois que
la ville allait parfaitement bien c'est
une maladie contagieuse et brutale comme
qui dirait des fièvres galopante de pays
étrangers
[Musique]
où
non
j'y vis tu vas tu as chéri bibi bien sûr
et
[Musique]
mais
où
j'ai comme l'impression question passe
des choses bizarres à bord comment dont
nos gardes ont indiqué qu'abdel d'après
mes estimations nous devons aller sur
clinton ils vont peut-être nous relâcher
ou nous massacrer mais c'est une
curieuse quand les parfums chéri bibi
nous allons faire relâche à kep tang
juste le temps nécessaire de charger des
provisions et faire du charbon tout le
monde dont sera consigné à bord je ne
veux pas d'histoires
seule la ficelle de barberaz nous
répartirons aussitôt capitaine on va
avoir d'importantes résolutions à
prendre
ah oui et alors alors il ya qu on ne
peut pas les prendre son chéri bibi
ici tout le monde est inquiet rapport à
lui et on ne va pas rester sans
s'étendre pas savoir ce qu'il devient
faites ce que vous voulez mais je n'ai
plus rien à vous dire
eh ben c'est pas compliqué nous
entrerons de force dans l'infirmerie par
mais ne venez pas vous plaindre après de
ne pas toucher les cinq millions de la
rançon quoi ah bon parce que ça a un
rapport avec la rançon
et pourquoi vous voulez que ce soit
voilà devenus raisonnables laisser chéri
bibi faire comme il l'entend et demandez
lui des explications après le fils elle
prépare ton paquet tu as tes papiers je
te donnerai les derniers détails de la
main même de cherubini tu es prêt non
je ne partirai pas sans avoir vu chéri
bibi c'est ton dernier mot c'est mon
dernier mot john normand garçons
j'ai peut-être tort mais je n'en
démordrai pas je partirai quand j'aurai
vu chérif
très bien
mais les 8 6
la ficelle obtint de pouvoir parler à
chéri bibi mais le kanak avait bien
insisté sur ce point sans pouvoir le
voir ce défendu le tapage paraît lacalle
c'est terrible ce truc-là a été
drôlement malades
je peux même pas serré la main je te
rappelle la ficelle que j'étais accordé
trois minutes pas une de plus écoute moi
bien la fille seule je sais que tu as
confiance en moi en sortant d'ici mardi
aux gueules de bois équipage que le
cannet tu m'as bien soigné il m'a sauvé
la vie
alors oui je le retiens et touche à un
bébé tout ce qu'il a fait pour moi
ça prouve sa récompense ya un million
pour lui
[Musique]
alors là là je suis sûr d'une marche ont
pas
ils ne seront jamais
et obtenu une rallonge du marquise et
ses six millions tu es demandé au
notaire à diem sent qu'ils ont cru sa
chute
[Musique]
un habitant
vraiment et de la reconnaissance pour
lui bien que ça
fait confiance
[Musique]
6 millions 6 millions devraient prévenir
la police
pour la carte et vous sent bien cette
crapule mans bien prévenu il turmes
seules marques et tous ses amis
si quoi que ce soit et menée contre eux
et puis allez dans savoir où il sans
vous 1 6 million 6 millions diable
allait-il faire dans ce bateau mais je
vous le répète il faut faire vite et
surtout garder la plus grande discrétion
quand même là la vie de monsieur le
marquis et en orge et bien bien bien
seulement il faut tout de même que
j'avertis smala partys c'est elle qui a
tout la signature alors rendez vous
demain shevell 6 millions ces bandits
ont des prétentions exemple 80 6
millions 6 millions vous vous rendez
compte et pas un sou moins ça ils me
l'ont bien précisé sinon va filtrer
monsieur le marquis dans un sac et on le
fera glisser sur une planche savonneuse
et plouf et si un vrai régal pour les
requins cet ampli story
vous
[Musique]
un type costaud comme chéri bibi
qui avait résisté aux vagues
la peau
ce
ce sont les meilleurs qui s'en vont
[Musique]
dès qu'il eut les 6 millions dans sa
sacoche la vie celle reparti aussitôt le
coeur étreindre le sinistre
pressentiment et si chéri bibi et et si
chéri bibi
mais non chéri bibi est indestructible
il fallait faire vite pour s'en
convaincre le retrouve et qu'on limite
n'est les plus plats qu'il aimait cette
morue à l'espagnol par exemple qu'il
affectionnait particulièrement
[Musique]
alors
y a rien de nouveau rien de nouveau tout
s'est bien passé depuis mon départ oui
mais chéri bibi
alors les ruches ça a marché
ouais ouais ouais je te demande chéri
bbc a marché c'est ça l'important
tu es devenu sourd petit bon dieu je te
demande comment va chéri bibi
il est mort
tu te souviens aussi des naufragés
robert bourrelier il est mort aussi
je m'en fout de ton envers ces chéri
bibi qui m'intéressait
[Musique]
ton millions le kanak tu vois je
respecte la volonté de chéri bibi les
autres n'en sont jamais rien tu as ma
parole
tout s'améliore
ils sont dans la sacoche et distribué ça
ne regarde plus
je te demande de me fiche la paix et
comme à nice puis à temps
la ficelle n'avais plus goût à rien
c'est à peine s'ils se nourrissaient il
restait des heures à se souvenir de
chéri bibi la ficelle son chéri bibi
était comme une plante sans soleil
il avait même quitté sa tenue de
fichiers et remis celle de matt clos en
signe de deuil
[Musique]
ses yeux
ce regard
une force irrésistible poussée la
ficelle à revoir ses yeux il ne pouvait
dire pourquoi
mais cela lui semblait important
[Musique]
à
manger la ficelle ça continue on va te
ramasser à la petite cuillère
voilà un coup non avant d'avoir retrouvé
chez un bébé
oui il est mort est le seul endroit où
tu puisses y retrouve les c'est en enfer
nous allons d'abord débarqué le marquis
vaut un peu plus tard vous serez déposé
sur une petite île du pacifique avec
deux mois de vivre les deux mois passés
nous préviendrons un bateau qui viendra
vous chercher
enfin mais pourquoi nous libérés
séparément pour des raisons de sécurité
désormais la ficelle voyait chéri bibi
partout sur le bateau ont commencé à
murmurer qu'il était devenu fou et que
tels ces chiens qui se laisse dépérir
sur la tombe de leurs maîtres ils
laisser mourir sa raison à petit feu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devant une assemblée de médecins et de
chercheurs le docteur pozzi a fait une
communication du plus haut intérêt
monsieur carvel à carhaix à prélever la
moitié de l'aorte abdominale d'une
chaîne dont il requiert le vaisseau avec
un morceau de péritoine la chaîne se
porte parfaitement d'autres expériences
vous prouver par la suite que dès que
que des greffes était possible qu'on
pouvait greffer toute sorte d'organe les
expériences de monsieur car elle ouvre
la la voie à une nouvelle chirurgie a
déclaré le docteur poesy
c'est pas vrai c'est pas possible circle
hack au lieu de manger ses clients comme
on le disait est découpée en lanières
pour des expériences comme ça si c'était
possible
à tous
fatalitas
l'espagnol face à la casse a bien dit
fatale et à ce vote à l'état ce marquis
talent et à ce shérif bbc trois séries
vvd toi bon la brute et
tu vas garder tout l'équipage tu sais
j'étais très malheureux quand j'ai
appris sa mort et maintenant tu vas tout
raconter un tu vas te l'expliquer aux
pieds de t'expliquer oui oui non ou
surtout de boeck le ghana qui sache que
d'user que ça peut lui faire un shark
utile c'est son secret des trucs changer
ma chance et c'est son secret
commencez pas reconnu officiellement par
par la médecine officielle quoi alors
c'est l'échafaud pour lui si ça vient et
connu le bas pour une fois la veuve
alors être pas fonctionner pour rien
tu sais c'est diabolique ce qu'il a
réussi à faire pourquoi elle vraiment
voir le marquis le kanak aidés qui est
un précurseur tous à servir à l'humanité
un jour les chirurgies esthétiques de
personnes il ya ciboulot crois moi j'ai
dire une chose marquer ou pas marqué un
pour moi tu es chéri bibi et puisse te
laisse plus que bien des femmes aux
tamouls n'ont pas pu pleinement faire
dans mon marquise à la morue
c'est vrai c'est vrai que maintenant
comme le grand maître tout est à toi
même si si
c'est ta femme maintenant
parce
ne me parle pas de ça
cette pensée la manche laonnoise
[Musique]
allez pense pas ça à ta santé
afin de donner le change aux kanaks la
ficelle a laissé sur sa couchette une
lettre on les faisait part de son
désespoir et de son désir de partager le
prétendu cygnus paul sort de chéri bibi
au fond de la mer écrivait-il
il retrouverait la paix ne pouvant plus
désormais survivre et tandis que les str
elle a commandé par le kanak continuer
sa route aventureuse
les deux hommes partaient vers leur
nouveau destin il n'y a plus de chéri
bibi
même lorsqu'il y en présence que chéri
bibi et la ficelle sur une plage déserte
pour brink excusez moi mais seulement si
monsieur le marquis le gaz donner la
peine
[Musique]